I regular home this is quite a spacious  home how many bathrooms you have in his  home well I don't know I think you do  know how many thousands do you have I  don't know I don't go around count my  bathroom well I did was that you yes  that was me I saw this creepy guy  counting bathrooms if the hell creepy  guy who would count bathrooms how you  know how many bathrooms I have in the  house I do a have 17 well you have  seventeen bathroom sir you need that at  my age my dad told me a long time ago  he'll need a lot of bathroom always  within 15 really my dad told me right  before he passed away he said you're  gonna hit 620 they're gonna give you two  rules number one never pass up a  bathroom number two use every erection  to its full potential  oh yes so if you have your wife's not  around you like hammer nails with it  [Applause]